[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من موسكو حيث اعلنت
روسيا اليوم توقيفها مراسل صحيفه وولز
الامريكيه بشبهه التجسس ننتقل الى البيت
الابيض الذي دان اعتقال الصحفي واصفا ما
حصل بغير مقبول فيما اعرب الخارجيه
الامريكيه عن قلق عميق واخيرا الى الخرطوم
التي تسودها مخاوف ايذاء مصير العمليه
الانتقاليه في ظل خلافات في الساعه
الاخيره تتعلق بمصير قوات الدعم السريع
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
وسط سجال وتوتر بين واشنطن وتل ابيب قلق
امريكي من التطورات الجاريه في اسرائيل
الائتلاف الحاكم في تل ابيب مصر على تمرير
تعديلات القضائيه
اليمين المتطرف يحشد انصاره وسط اجراءات
امنيه مشدده وزعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يقول ان هدف المظاهره سفك الدماء
في اشد اجراء ضد صحفي اجنبي منذ بدء حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا حبس مراسل امريكي
بتهمه التجسس في روسيا صحيفه وولد تنفي
التهمه بشده موسكو تقول انه تم القبض على
الصحفي متلبسا البيت الابيض يعتبر الاجراء
غير مقبول
والخارجيه الامريكيه تعرب عن قلقها العميق
تحذير من المفوضيه الاوروبيه مستقبل
علاقات اوروبا مع بيجين يحدده موقف الصين
من الحرب في اوكرانيا ورساله من وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه الصين مستعده للعمل مع
الجيش الروسي على عده جبهات
غموض سياسيا في السودان القوات المسلحه
تجدد التزامها بالعمليه السياسيه والدعم
السريع تؤكد دعمها للجيش قومي مهني واحد
وتاكيدات بتوقيع الاتفاق النهائي للعمليه
الانتقاليه في موعده وترقب لنتائج اجتماعا
بين قوى مدنيه والمكون العسكري
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا حاله الغموض السياسيه في
السودان في ظل الخلافات التي ظهرت في
الساعات الاخيره والمتعلقه بدمج قوات
الدعم السريع في الجيش السوداني خلافات
تلقي بظلالها على الاتفاق النهائي بشان
العمليه السياسيه والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم ما التداعيات المحتمله
للخلاف حول دمج قوات الدعم السريع وجاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي نحو 45%
يتوقعون عرقله المراحل النهائيه للعمليه
الانتقاليه قرابه 32% يرون ان الخلافه
سيعمق الانقسام داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
بينما قال نحو ثلاثه وعشرين في المئه ان
الخلافه سينتقل الى الشارع السوداني
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وفي فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نرصد
احياء الذكرى السابعه والاربعين ليوم
الارض مسيرات بمشاركه الالاف من
الفلسطينيين داخل الخط الاخضر ومخاوف من
مصادره مزيد من الاراضي
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر قريبه من رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو ان الرساله
التي تريد اسرائيل ارسالها من خلال
التواصل الدبلوماسي مع واشنطن لان الحوار
بين الطرفين قائم ولكن الائتلاف الحاكم
مصر على تمرير التعديلات القضائيه وكانت
صحيفه اسرائيل هيام اورددت ان وزير
الخارجيه ايلي كوهين سيجري الليله محادثه
هاتفيه مع نظيره الامريكي
وقد اشاد كهين بعمق العلاقات بين تل ابيب
وواشنطن وتميزها وقال وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي في تغريده ان الولايات المتحده
هي الحليف الاكبر لاسرائيل وان العلاقه
بين البلدين وثيقه ودافئه
وقد اعرب المتحدث باسم البنتاجون عن قلق
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من التطورات
الجاريه في اسرائيل وفي لقاء خاص مع
الجزيره دعا رايدر القاده الاسرائيليين
للتوصل الى تسويه تستعيد الهدوء وفق
تعبيره
لدينا بعض المخاوف بشان التطورات الحاصله
في اسرائيل قد سمعتم النقاداتنا بمن فيهم
الرئيس بايدن ووزير الدفاع استون يحثون
القاده الاسرائيليين على ايجاد تسويه في
سبيل خفض تصعيد الموقف واستعاده الهدوء
نعتقد ان هذا هو افضل طريق لاسرائيل للمضي
قدما
في هذه الاثناء يحتشد فتل ابيب الالاف من
انصار اليمين الاسرائيلي ومن المؤيدين
لخطوات الائتلاف الحكومي بزعامه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الرميه الى احداث
تغييرات على السلطه القضائيه وردد
المتظاهرون شعارات تقول الشعب يريد اصلاحا
قانونيا كما رفعوا صورا للرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن تحمل عبارات ناريه وذلك على
خلفيه تصريحاته الاخيره التي قال فيها انه
لن يدعو نتنياهو لزياره البيت الابيض
قريبا من جانبها قال زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه ان مظاهره اليمين في تل ابيب
اعتداء على الديمقراطيه وتهدف الى سفك
الدماء
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب الدكتور مردخاي
كيدار استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
نائب المساعد الاسبق لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي سيد جوال ابدا معك مع حدود
الخلاف بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واسرائيل الى اين يمكن ان يصل
ولم يسعدني ان اكون معكم
الوضع حاليا هو وضع السائل حقيقه متغير
والرئيس قلق للغايه حول مجريات الامور حول
التغييرات التي يقترحها رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو طبعا الكره الان في ملعب نتنياهو
هل هو سيبقي على التوافق في الاراء في
اسرائيل ازاء اي التغييرات في النظام
القضائي ام لا الرئيس بايدن طبعا سيكون
موقفك رده فعل لما يحدث في تل ابيب هو
الرئيس بايدن صديق وحريف لاسرائيل
ومن المهم جدا ان يبقى مثل هذا الدعم
للديمقراطيه النظام الاسرائيلي سيد جويل
تقول بان الكره في ملعب نتنياهو ومصادر
مقربه من الحكومه تقول ان الائتلاف ماض في
تعديلاته
الرئيس الوزراء مضى قدما بما اقترحه من
قبل فان هذا سيزيد من الاحتكاك القائم
حاليا ولان الشعب الاسرائيلي نفسه لن يبقى
مكتوف الايدي فقد راينا تلك الاحتجاجات
على مدى ثلاثه اشهر الماضيه هي ليست
احتجاز ليوم او يومين وما عنيته بان الكره
في ملعب رئيس الوزراء هو ان عليه ان ياتي
بمجموع القوى وليعمل مع المعارضه كما
يحاول الرئيس دوله اسرائيل الان للتوصل
الى حل يرضي جميع الاطراف وهذا ما يتطلع
اليه الرئيس بايدن لهذا السبب نحن بانتظار
ما سيحصل في الاسابيع المقبله القادمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت واضحه في
موقفها هل اسرائيل
مستعده بتمسكها بموقفها او لائتلاف
الحكومي مستعد لتطور هذا الخلاف
ليس هناك خلاف جذري بين اسرائيل
والاداره الامريكيه هناك خلافات وهذا ليست
المره الاخرى
المره الاولى كانت هناك خلافات حول اتفاق
اتفاق النووي في 2015 عندما جاء نتنياهو
ليخاطب الكونغرس بالرغم من رفض اوباما في
تلك الايام لذلك وكانت هناك قتيله السنوات
جدل هنا وهناك على الكثير من المجالات
ولكن العلاقات الاسلاميه الامريكيه هي
عميقه والسميكه
ومن قديم الزمان
يعني سبحتم ما جرى شبهتم ما جرى اليوم
بالخلاف الذي كان حول الاتفاق النووي
الايراني ولكن الظروف كانت مختلفه حتى في
الداخل الاسرائيلي كان الرئيس نتنياهو
لديه دعم شعبي يقف وراءه اليوم هنالك جزء
من الاسرائيليين يطالب بالعدول عن هذه
التعديلات
ولكن من يطالب بالعدوله لم تعادلات هم
الاقليه التي يخاصروا في الانتخابات هناك
اكثريه
والقاعده للديمقراطيه لان الاغلبيه هي
الحاكمه لان حكم الاقليه هو ديكتاتوريه
كما يدور في الكثير من الدول العربيه نحن
لسنا دول في يعني في هذه المنطقه نحن دوله
ديمقراطيه بامتياز وهذا ما يسمح للاغلبيه
بالحكم ولكن عليها ان تراعي الاقليه ايضا
ولذلك هناك اليوم محادثات تحت رعايه رئيس
الدوله
وان شاء الله سنصل الى بر الامان مع هذه
المحادثات وكل ما
لن ادخل في جدال الاقليه والاغلبيه ولكن
هل وصلت العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
واسرائيل الى حد ان يرسل الرئيس رساله
شديده اللهجه الى رئيس الحكومه كما يقول
موقع ولا الى ان يصل
بالمشرعين ان يوقع المشرعون الديمقراطيون
مطالبين الجانب الامريكي بتعديل سياسات
اتجاه اسرائيل هل حدث ذلك سابقا في تاريخ
العلاقات بين الجانبين
كانت هناك من
في بعض الاوقات خطابات مماثله لذلك ولكن
التعاون العسكري والاستخباري والاقتصادي
والعملي بماذا الاعمال بين اسرائيل
وامريكا لا تتغير قدر
ولذلك هناك ربما جو ليس
بنعيم
للجانبين بين بين
العاصمه هنا
ولكن هذا سيمر
كحابه صيف سيد جول في حال اصر الائتلاف
الحاكم على المدير قدما في هذه
التعديلات كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع ذلك
التغييرات او الاصلاحات القضائيه مضت قدما
كما كان
حاول او يحاولوا رئيس الوزراء باتجاه
التمرير هذا سيخلق مشكلات لانها ستكون
هناك حاله من الاحتجاج نحن لسنا من العدل
ان نقول ان المحتجين هم مجرد اقليه صغيره
وقبل اليوم الذي غير فيه رئيس الوزراء من
موقفه قليلا كان هناك ثلاثه ارباع المليون
اسرائيلي كانوا موجودين في الشوارع
النقابات العمال والخطوط الطيران القوات
الاحتياط هذا ليس مجرد اقليه في اقل تقدير
الولات المتحده لن تكون سلبيه عندما يكون
لدينا الصديق وحريف ديمقراطي واسرائيل
يتحرك بهذا الطريقه ضد الديمقراطيه
لحد الان يعني لم تجبني عن كيف يمكن ان
تتصرف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في حال
مضت هذه التعديلات
ردود فعل مشابهه لما رايناه الان سنرى
انخراطا من اداره بايدن اداره بايدن كانت
تمخرط من وراء الكواليس لمده اسابيع مع
رئيس الوزراء
لكنها لم تصبر عن النتيجه المرجوه لكن
الشعب الاسرائيلي خرج وعبر عن موقفه وخاصه
عندما قال رئيس الوزراء وزير الدفاع ليس
لانه لم يستطع اداره القوات العسكري
الاسرائيليه لكن هذا كان خطوه ابعد مما
ينبغي ذهب اليها رئيس الوزراء وهذا ما جعل
البيت الابيض ينخرط ويندفع بهذه الاندفاع
ليضمن ان الديمقراطيه والمجتمع الاسرائيلي
سيتم الحفاظ عليهما اعتقد اننا سنرى
انخراطا مستمرا ودعما من اجل
عمليه ديمقراطيه جامعه لا تقصي احدا من
اجل الضمان الاستقرار اسرائيل
جبلنا المساعد الاسبق لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه كنت معنا من ميريلاند شكرا لك
والشكر موصول للسيد مردخاي كيداير كان
معنا
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجات الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان واشنطن تشعر بقلق بالغ ازاء
الانباء عن احتجاز روسيا صحفيا امريكيا
يعمل لصاحه لصالح صحيفه
ما يجري بالقمع والترهيب وطالب البيت
الابيض المواطنين الامريكيين بمغادره
روسيا على الفور وكان الكريم قد قال ان
اعتقال مراسل صحيفه
لم يكن لمجرد الاشتباه مشيرا الى ان
المراسل القي القبض عليه متلبسا بالتجسس
بدورها قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ان نشاط مراسل في مدينه
يكترو يكترين برج لا يمت بصله للعمل
الصحفي
هذا واصرت محكمه ليفورتوفا في موسكو قرارا
اصدرت قرارا يقضي بتوقيف مراسل صحيفه وولد
ايفان جيروش كوفيتش حتى التاسع والعشرين
من مايو ايار المقبل على ذمه التحقيق
بتهمه التجسس في المقابل نفت صحيفه
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي لمراسلها
واكدت سعيها للافراج الفوري عنه وقالت
الصحيفه ان العمل الصحفي في روسيا بات
اكثر صعوبه بعد غزو بوتين لاوكرانيا وقمع
المعارضه المحليه حسب تعبير الصحيفه
وذكرت وكاله ان مراسله
الذي اعتقل في روسيا يواجه عقوبه قد تصل
الى عشرين عاما سجنا اذا ادينا بالتجسس
ونقلت الوكاله عن مسؤولا روسيا رفيع قوله
انه من السابق لاوانه الحديث عن اي صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى رغم ابرام موسكو وواشنطن
صفقات من هذا النوع من قبل كما نقلت عن
خبراء قانونيين قولهم ان التحقيقات في
قضايا تجسس كهذه قد تستغرق ما بين سنه
وسنه ونصف ويعد اتهام مراسل وولد بالتجسس
هو الاول من نوعه لصحفيا اجنبيا منذ حقبه
الاتحاد السوفيتي وجاء في اتهامه انه يعمل
تحت تعليمات امريكيه للحصول على معلومات
سريه تتعلق بمركب صناعي عسكريا روسي
اعتقال الصحفيه الامريكي يعيد الى الواجهه
ملف المحتجزين بين البلدين نتعرف على هذا
الملف اكثر في التقرير التالي
احتجاز السلطات الروسيه ايفنجر شوكوفيتش
الصحفيه في جورنيل واتهامه بالتجسس يعيدان
للواجهه ملف المحتجزين من كلا الطرفين
وبحسب المعلومات المتوفره تحت جزم روسيا
ثلاثه مواطنين امريكيين
جندي سابق في المارينز وعمل عند القاء
القبض عليه مديرا تنفيذيا في شركه امنيه
اوقف في موسكو نهايه عام 2018 وحكم عليه
بالسجن 16 عاما بتهمه التجسس
مارك فوجيل استاذ تاريخ وقف في اغسطس عام
2021 بتهمه حيازه الممنوعات وحكم عليه
بالسجن 14 عاما اللافت في قضيه ان
الولايات المتحده لم تعلن ان احتجازه في
روسيا غير
قانونيز وصل الى روسيا محاولا استعاده
اولاده من زوجته السابقه روسيه الاصل
اعتقل بتهمه اساءه معامله اولاده خلال
جولات المفاوضات السابقه بين موسكو واشنطن
حول تبادل السجناء لطالما برز اسمه دون
البقيه
وفي الصفقه الاخيره التي تم تبادل فيكتور
باوت مقابل بريتني جرينر اكد الرئيس
الامريكي ان المفاوضين قاموا بجل ما في
وسعهم محاولين ان تشمل الصفقه
الروس تمسكوا برفض الافراج عنه
تغيب المعلومات المحققه عن مواطنين روس
محكومين في الولايات المتحده يعرف منهم
الكسندر فينيك وهو مواطن روسي القي القبض
عليه في فرنسا وسلم الى الولايات المتحده
لاتهامه بتبييض الاموال والابتزاز
والقرصنه
ويبقى فاديم كراسيكوف العقده الابرز يقضي
الرجل عقوبه في المانيا بتهمه قتل مواطن
جورجي عام 2019 والذي تطالب موسكو
بالافراج عنه
حاولت واشنطن اقناع برلين باستخدامه ورقه
للتفاوض مع روسيا لاطلاق الامريكي
لكن الحكومه الالمانيه لم تستجب للمطالب
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من واشنطن كيلي فلاهوس كبيره
الباحثين في معهد كوينسي ومن موسكو اولغا
كريسنياك استاذه العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
الابحاث الوطنيه ابدا معك سيده سيده كليب
كيف تنظرون الى توقيت هذا الاعتقال
اكيد متاكد هناك ادانات كثيره في واشنطن
ضد هذا الموضوع البيت الابيض ادانا
الموضوع
والوزاره الدفاع ايضا
داله هذا الاعتقال جمعيات الصحفيين في كل
العالم ادانوا هذا الاعتقال وهذه اول مره
يجري فيها اعتقال صحفي
امريكي لدى قوه اجنبيه منذ ايام
الثمانينيات القرن الماضي في الحرب
البارده وانا اتذكر كانك اضوى في الاعلام
ارا ذلك امر له تاثير سيء جدا على
الصحفيين والمقررين
الجانب الروسي لو سمحتي للجانب الروسي
يقول بانه تم اعتقال الصحفي متلبسا
هذه كلمتهم هذه روايتهم وانا
حيث اعمل اين
نحن لدينا قصه
محدثه اليوم فيها مسؤول سابق في المخابرات
الامريكيه ان هذه الساعه اصدر القرار فيها
1977 وهم نبي عشره باسم كصحفيين انهم
جواسيس اذ لم يعدوا يعتقلوا اي صحفي على
انه
جاسوس لان هذا ذلك خطر وهو يرى والكثير من
الناس هنا يرون انه من غير محتمل اطلاقا
ان هذا الصحفي الذي يعمل معه هذه الصحيفه
منذ عام 1922 عفوا 2022
وعده وكالات
اخباريه منها الوكاله الفرنسيه ان يكون
جاسوسا يعمل لصالح امريكا ونامل ان يحصل
على محاكمه عادله لك لحد الان
المحاميه الذي وكلته
يتواصل مع الصحفي وقد حينا
محكمه سمحت له بذلك لكن لم يحصل لحد الان
الاتصال معه والسفاره لم تحصل عليه اتصال
معه ايضا وبالتالي يقول بانه تم السماح له
بالاتصال ساعود اليك دعينا اسمع من السيده
اولغا سيده اولغا والاعتقال الاول منذ عام
لصحفيا امريكيه او لامريكي حسب ما اعتقد
هل هو اعتقال سياسي
كلما نعرفه يتعلق بمزاعم ضد هذا الصحفي
والجانب الامريكي يرفضها لكن حتى اتمام
العمليه والتي لم تنتهي بعد لن نعرف على
وجه اليقين بناء على ما يقول هو المسؤولون
الروس المعلومات طبعا هي غير متوفره للعام
لكن انا اود ان انظر من منظور مختلف عاده
السفارات هي التي تتبع المعلومات على
الارض وهذا يعني
الارساله تقارير وجمع معلومات استخباريه
وهذا جزء مهم طبعا
لاتخاذ قرارات مهمه فيما يتعلقوا بالبلدان
الاخرى واذا ما اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
ان طرد دبلوماسيين يتم منذ سنوات
وهذا يعني بان
الصحفيين وربما هم يقومون بنوع من العمل
الدبلوماسي من خلال جمع معلومات استخباريه
ربما هذه هي خلفيه تهمه جمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه والتي طبعا لا ينبغي ان
يفعلها الصحفيون والمراسلون سيده اولغا
ذكرتي ان كل ما نعرفه الى حد الان هي
مزاعم وليس هنالك معلومات واضحه ما قيل او
ما تم نشره من قبل السلطات الروسيه بان
هذا الصحفي كان يجمع معلومات في منطقه
فيها مصانع حربيه لا يمكن ان يكون ذلك
لتقرير على سبيل المثال
لتقليل صحفي
اخرى هي معلومات سريه للغايه غير متوفره
للعامه وكل ما نتحدث عنه هو من قبيل
التكهنات لكن علينا نعرف ان هذا الصحفي من
اصول اوروسيه اذا بالتاكيد هو تحدث اللغه
الروسيه ولديه قدره للوصول الى الشعب
الروسي وجمع بعض المعلومات اذا في هذه
الحال علينا ان ننتظر لنرى بقيه العلامات
الرسميه وكيف ستوفر للراي العام لكن علينا
ان ننظر في جميع الاحتمالات وكل هذا
المسار انا لا اعتقد انها تاتي من فراغ
لابد وان لها اساس من الصحه طيب بانتظار
ما الذي سيرد من معلومات ولكن سيده اولغا
عندما تقولين بانه يتحدث الروسيه هل يشكل
ذلك عامل ادانه لصحفي في بلد ما اذا كان
يتحدث لغه البلد باختصار لو سمحتي
لو ان الصحفي هو طبعا معرفته باللغه
الروسيه تعطيه مزيه وافضليه لكن انا اعتقد
ان المزاعم بالتاكيد لها اصل لكن هي ليست
تهمه جنائيه ان تتحدث اللغه الروسيه كصحفي
بالطبع هذه ليست القضيه القضيه هي قضيه
تجسس اعود اليك سيداتي سيده ما الادوات
التي تمتلكها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للافراج عن هذا الصحفي لانه وزير الخارجيه
وصف ما جرى بالترهيب
يا امين
مما قراته خلال هذا اليوم ان البيت الابيض
يحاول ان يتصل
من نظرائهم في وكذلك
يحاول الاتصال بنظيره وزاره الخارجيه
تحاول الاتصال
بالاتصال
بالقنصليه
تجعل القنصليه تستطيع ان تتصل بالصحفي وهو
في روسيا ولكن حسب علمي لم يستطيعوا لحد
الان الاتصال به وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك
الكثير من الحديث والكثير من الناس من
المحررين والصحفيين في الصحيفه واعضاء
اسرته وكذلك
الخبره اللي انا اعمل فيها وان المسؤول
السابق في المخابرات الامريكيه التي
ذكرتهم قبل قليل يقول ان هذا متجر عن
سابقه قصد وترصد لجعله مثالا لتخويف بقيه
الصحفيين الذي يعملون في روسيا وان روسيا
اصدرت معلومات قوانين ضد التظليل الاعلامي
وحول العمل والاطلاع على النشاطات
العسكريه وهناك كثير من الصحفيين اضطروا
الهروب من البلاد اذ من خطر جدا العمل
هناك وبالتالي هو قد يكون فقط قدوه لاخذني
او
مثالا للاخرين يطلقوا سراحه سريعا وانا
افهم انه محاكمه قد ستبدا في نهايه شهر
مايو ايار القادم
وبالتالي ثم تقديمه الى المحكمه شكرا لك
سيده
الباحثين في معهد كوين سي كنت معنا من
واشنطن ومن موسكو اولغا سينياك استاذه
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الابحاث الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
حضرت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
لافندر لاين من ان مستقبل علاقات الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع الصين مرهون بموقفها من حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا لكنها اكدت في الوقت
نفسه ان مصلحه اوروبا تقتضي مواصله الحوار
مع العملاق الاسيوي وفق تعبيرها وجاءت
تصريحات المسؤوله الاوروبيه قبيل زياره
لها الى بيجين الاسبوع المقبل برفقه
الرئيس الفرنسي امام وبعد اسبوعين من
زياره الرئيس الصيني
الى موسكو
على مؤشر الحرب الاوكرانيه يريد الاتحاد
الاوروبي اعاده ضبط علاقاته مع الصين وتلك
المراجعه يمكن ان تبدا مع زياره الرئيس
الفرنسي الاسبوع المقبل الى بيجين مرفوقا
برئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
عشيه الزياره اطلقت بوندرلاين ما يمكن
اعتباره تقييما مقتضبا للعلاقات بين
القطبين العالميين الكبيرين اظهر محوريه
الموقف من حرب اوكرانيا في تحديد بوصله
العلاقات الاوروبيه الصينيه
على الصين كعضو دائم في مجلس الامن ان
تطلع بدور لحمايه القيم والمبادئ التي هي
في صميم ميثاق الامم المتحده وعليها ان
تقوم بدور لتحقيق السلام العادل والدائم
وكيف تتفاعل الصين مع الحرب في اوكرانيا
سيكون عاملا اساسيا في تحديد شكل العلاقه
بين اوروبا والصين ليس المطلوب اوروبيا ان
تقاطع بيجين روسيا بل ان تستخدم نفوذها
المفترض لدى حليفتها لاقناعها بوقف الحرب
على اوكرانيا التي دخلت عامها الثاني دون
مؤشر على اي حسم قريب
ورغم الاستياء الغربي من زياره الرئيس
الصيني الاخيره الى موسكو والتقليل من
اهميه مبادرته بالتسويه في اوكرانيا فان
زياره ماكرون
وقبلها زياره رئيس الحكومه الاسبانيه قد
تعكس رغبه الاوروبيين في استثمار ثقل
الدولي في حلحله تلك الحرب المندلعه في
قلب قارتهم لا سيما مع ما يعتبره بعضهم
تعنت امريكيا ازاء التسويح ويشكو الاتحاد
الاوروبي من ان علاقتهم مع الصين غدت اكثر
تعقيدا واقل ثقه فبيجين كثفت خلال السنوات
الماضيه قمعها داخليا وهي على الصعيد
الخارجي اصبحت اكثر هجوميه واستبدلت حقبه
اصلاح وانفتاح بعصر من الامن والسيطره على
حد قول الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تؤكد اللافكاك من
العلاقه مع الصين والمطلوب هو الحد من
المخاطر على اوروبا على حد تعبيرها
في الان نفسه لا تبدو بجين اقل اهتماما
بعلاقاتها مع الاوروبيين ففي منتصف فبراير
الماضي زار وزير الخارجيه الصيني عده
عواصم اوروبيه ولمده اسبوع كامل يومها
قالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان جوله الوزير
تهدف الى تطوير العلاقات الثنائيه وتعزيز
الثقه الاستراتيجيه المتبادله بين الصين
واوروبا
ذلك مع اعلان وزاره الدفاع الصينيه مستعده
للعمل مع الجيش الروسي على شبهات عده حول
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور
زياد ماجد واستاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس اهلا بك يا
دكتور زياد دكتور زياد ما مدى التوافق
الامريكي الاوروبي في مقاربه العلاقه مع
الصين
اعتقد ان هناك تميزان بين المقاربتين
الامريكيه والاوروبيه امريكا تنظر الى
الصين كمنافس اول اقتصاديا وطبعا ليس فقط
في منطقه اسيا وفي منطقه تايوان وبحر
الصين لكن ايضا على صعيد التبادل التجاري
وميزان المدفوعات مع الكثير من الدول في
امريكا الجنوبيه وفي افريقيا بالنسبه
لاوروبا الموضوع ليس فقط اقتصاديا او
يرتبط برقع جغرافيه تحاول الاقتصادات
الاوروبيه التمدد باتجاهها هناك قلق من
وجود كيانات كبرى تغرق اوروبا بالبضائع
ولديها قوه عسكريه اكبر من القوه
الاوروبيه
وتراهن كذلك هذه القوه الاخرى على خلافات
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي يحاول الاوروبيون
الان خاصه انهم الاكثر تعرضا لتبعات الحرب
في اوكرانيا ان يفصلوا الموقف الصيني
والروسي وان لا يقاربوا بكين وموسكو
كحليفين وثيقين لا مجال للتفاوض مع بكين
مثلا لثنيها عن بعض الامور وهذا
ياخذونه على الامريكيين الذين حتى الان
يتعاملون مع الصين وروسيا كحليفين من دون
السعي الى ابعادك او او تمييزهما عن بعض
الى العلاقه بين روسيا والصين فيما يتعلق
باوكرانيا قالت بان يعني صلب العلاقه مع
الصين تتمحور على موقفها من الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وانها تعول على دور صيني
لحلها هل يمكن ان توافق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على هذا الدور الصيني
حتى الان امريكا متحفظه تماما لكن لنرى
فقط كيف تموضعت الصين حتى الان الصين لم
تعترف باستقلال دومباس ولم تعترف بضم
جزيره القرم ما زالت الخريطه الاوكرانيه
بنسبه اليها كما كانت قبل الحرب كما انها
لم ترسل العسكريا اعم
لكنها لم ترسل ما طلبته موسكو في الفتره
الاخيره فاستعدت موسكو عن ذلك بالدرون
الايراني بضخائر من كوريا الشماليه كما ان
الصين لم تصوت مره في الامم المتحده الى
جانب قرارات تدين روسيا لكنها كانت تمتنع
عن التصويت ولا تصوت مع الدول التي تؤيد
روسيا لذلك الصين ابقت على هامش تحرك تريد
ان تستفيد منه لكي تطرح مبادرتها وبعض
الاوروبيين يريدون تشجيع زيلنسكي على اخذ
المبادره الصينيه بشكل جدي ويطلبون من
الامريكيين ان يصطفوا خلف زيلنسكي لا ان
يملا عليه بعض الامور لذلك المرحله هذه
اعتقد حساسه مكرونه يزور بكين ورئيسه
وزراء ايطاليا ستزور بكين الرئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ثم هناك زيارات اخرى
مثل رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي وغير ومسؤولين
اخرين هناك مفاضات جديه مع الصين التي
تريد ان تظهر ذكرنا بان بين الجانبين على
المستوى العسكري في تصاعد في الوقت عينه
فيما يتعلق باوكرانيا الرئيس الصيني الى
حد الان لم يتحدث مع الرئيس الاوكراني
فيما يتعلق بالوساطه الصينيه العلاقه
الروسيه الصينيه كيف تصفها في اي مرحله هي
الان
هي هي حكما في مرحله متقدمه لحاجه روسيه
اولا
اقتصادات اسيا ولتعاون وثيق مع الصين
كبديل عن العقوبات وعن العلاقه المتوتره
جدا مع الدول الغربيه من جهتها الصين التي
يستمر نموها الاقتصادي وتسيدها عمليات
التبادل التجاري والسلعي مع الكثير من
الدول تحتاج لطاقه ومصادر الطاقه يمكن
لروسيا ان تمدها بها كما يمكنها ان تمدها
بالقمح الذي تحتاج اليه ومجموعه
يعني عناصر زراعيه وغذائيه تنقص في
الاكتفاء الذاتي الصيني لكن في نفس الوقت
هناك خشيه لدى الصين من ان ترتبط قضيه
تايوان مثلا بقضيه اوكرانيا لذلك يبقى
التعاون العسكري والتنسيق العسكري خارج
جبهات الحروب هو اقرب الى اظهار وتظهير
هذه هذا التحالف ليكون للقوه الثانيه
والثالثه في العالم شان يستطيعان من خلاله
كل على حدا التفاوض وهذا اعتقد مساله مهمه
دكتور زياده ماجد واستاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعات الامريكيه في باريس كنت معنا من
باريس
شكرا
[موسيقى]
في السودان قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر
يوسف للجزيره ان اليوم شهد اجتماعات
ولقاءات بين القوى المنخرطه في العمليات
السياسيه بما فيهم ممثلين للمكون العسكري
وكذلك لقاءات بين القوى المدنيه المختلفه
لبحث سير العمليات السلميه في السودان
واضاف يوسف ان لجنه صياغه توصيات ورشه
الاصلاح العسكري والامني ستواصل جلساتها
يوم غد الجمعه في اطار مهمه اكمال عملها
واشار يوسف في حال لم تحسم كل القضايا
سيتم الدعوه لاجتماعا موسعا لمناقشه تعديل
الجدول الزمني لاكمال هياكل السلطه
المدنيه
حاله من الارتباك السياسي والامني في
الساحه السودانيه خلف انسحاب الجيش من
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري ارتباك سرعه
المؤسسه العسكريه لتبديده بتاكيد التزامها
بالعمليه السياسيه الجيش السوداني قال انه
ينتظر اكتمال عمل اللجان الفنيه بشان
عمليه الدمج القوات وينتظر تواصل اللجان
الى جداول زمنيه تبين المده التي تحتاج
اليها لدمج قوات الدعم السريع وبقيه
الحركات المسلحه وقت المسلحه اتسع خلال
الفتره الانتقاليه لايكون هنالك الجيش
وطني واحد وذلك باكمال الترتيبات الامنيه
للحركات التي وقعت على اتفاق سلام جبهه
ايضا واتدعم السريع يجب ان يتم ادائها
داخل القوات المسلحه ويجب ان نصل في نهايه
الفكره الانتقاليه الى جيش وطني واحد قوات
الدعم السريع اكدت من جانبها التزامها
بالوصول الى جيش مهني موحد وبمواصله
المباحثات بروح ايجابيه في اللجان الفنيه
المشتركه مساله الدمج الدعم السريع هي
واحده من الموضوعات لان الدعم السريع قدم
ورقه شامله فيها اصلاح الشامل للمنظومه
الامنيه والعسكريه بما في ذلك الجيش الدعم
السريع الشرطه جهاز المخابرات يعني رؤيه
شامله كامله متكامله ترتكز على اشياء
اساسيه
مراقبون لشان السوداني ارجعوا العزمه بين
اطراف المكون العسكري الى عدم الاتفاق على
جداول زمنيه تحدد الفتره التي تدمج فيها
قوات الدعم السريع ما تسرب عن الفترات
المحدده او المتوقعه هي الدعم السريع
الطالب بعشر سنوات ولكن الوساطه اقترحت
خمس سنوات وكلها ت زيد عن الفتره
الانتقاليه وعلى الرغم من هذه الخلافات
فان الموقعين على الاتفاق الايطالي يرون
ان التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي مطلع
ابريل القادم لا يزال ممكنا
تسابق اطراف العمليه السياسيه الزمن
لتدليل العقبات الظاهر منها والمستتر من
اجل التوقيع على نسخه النهائيه للاتفاق
السياسي وتجنب الدخول في متاهات قد تعطل
مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي في البلاد
الطاهر المرضي الجزيره الخرطوم
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم اسماعيل لاويس
المبعوث الخاص لمنظمه ايجاد الى السودان
وعضو الاليه ثلاثيه المسهله للعمليه
السياسيه في السودان سيد اسماعيل ما هي
فرص توقيع الاتفاق النهائي في موعده في ظل
ما شاهدناه في الايام الاخيره
رمضان كريم فيرس اولا رمضان كريم
ان المعنيين بهذه العمليه فعلا قرروا
واتفقوا على جدول زمني واضح بالنسبه
للجميع وهو في الوقت ذاته وعد يقدم للشعب
السوداني بانهم سيتوجهون هذه العمليه
وياخذونها الى طريق النجاح
هناك تحديات وصعوبات بسيطه كما هو الحال
في كل مثل هذه العمليات ولكن ما نعتقد انه
هو خاصه فيما يتعلق بالسيره الثلاثيه انهم
العمليه الثلاثيه انها ملتزمون معك جميع
اطراف اصحاب العلاقه بان هذه العمليه سوف
تستمر
وستظهر ثمارها
الزمني هو اصحاب العلاقه وهذا فعلا هو اما
ينتظره الشعب ويتوقعه الشعب السوداني من
قادته من الناحيه من قادته السياسين بشكل
عام وصفت
وصفت الخلافات بانها بسيطه معوقات بسيطه
هل ما يجري اليوم وامكانيه حسب ما يقول
يوسف تاجيل الموعد النهائي للتوقيع على
الاتفاق بسيط
كما تعلمون الواقع ان اصحاب العلاقه
قد وضعوا هذا الجدول الزمني دون اي ضغوط
خارجيه فكما تعلمون هذه عمليه تولى
قيادتها وملكيتها السودانيون
اتفق على التوقيع في الاول من ابريل نيسان
بمشيئه الله سيكون ذلك اتفاق نهائي سياسي
لكن الى ان ياتي ذلك الموعد فان اللجنه
الثلاثيه خاصه وكل الشعب السودان يمدون
الاعتقاد والتوقع بان السياسيين
بوعودهم وحتى ذلك الوقت لن نقوم باي تقديم
اي تكهنات او احتمالات لما سينجح وما ينجح
سيد اسماعيل اذا كان السياسيون سيكون
بوعودهم ماذا عن المكون العسكريين واضح
بانه لم يشارك في الجلسه الاخيره
وخلا وخلافات واضحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش
في الوقت الحالي حتى الجيش ذكروا انه منذ
منذ شهر اكتوبر تشرين الاول من السنه
الماضيه 2022 هم يقودون البلاد وهم كقاده
البلاد هم ملزمون
بكلمتهم ووعدهم وقد سبق ان وعد الشعب
السوداني في عده مناسبات
بان الاول من نساء سيكون هو يوم توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي النهائي وهذا ينطبق ايضا
على السياسيين المدنيين
وكذلك على المكون العسكري الذين يتحملون
نفس المسؤوليه وهم مدينون بذلك ماء ازاء
الشعب السوداني في هذا الوضع السياسي
ويبدون يحصر شيئا مختلفا في البلاد وان
هذا وان العسكر
والمدنيين ينبغي ان يتعاونوا وندعوهم الى
ذلك وان يوفوا بالتزاماتهم ووعودهم لتحقيق
السلام والاستقرار والتنميه لهذا البلد
وللشعب
هذه هذا الراي فان على الطرفين ان
يلتزما
وبوعودهما وينفذها كما وعدوا ابناء الشعب
بها شكرا لك سيد اسماعيل وايس المبعوث
الخاص لمنظمه ايجاد الى السودان وعضو
الاليه الثلاثيه المسهله للعمليه السياسيه
في السودان
[موسيقى]
يوم الارض الفلسطينيه قضيه وجودنا وتحدد
مستمر منذ عقود بين الفلسطينيين من داخل
الخط الاخضر والسلطات الاسرائيليه في
الثلاثين من مارس عام
1976 اشعل قرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه
برئاسه اسحاق اسحاق رابيين وزير الامن
ووزير الامن شيموم معركه الارض والمسكن
بعد تحريك مخطط اسرائيلي لمصادره 21 الف
دونم من اراضي سهل البطوف والمل والشاغور
في الجليل وتعود ملكيتها لمزارعين من
بلدات سخنين وعرابه ودير حنا وعرب السواعد
دفع الفلسطينيون داخل الخط الاخضر في
المظاهرات ضد الاستيطان ومصادره الاراضي
ضريبه الدم باستشهاد سته منهم في مناطق
الجليل والمثلث وطول كرم ومنذ النك حتى
احداث يوم الارض الاول صادرت اسرائيل نحو
مليون دونم من الفلسطينيين داخل الخط
الاخضر في الجليل والمثلث والنقب والمدن
الساحليه المختلطه وذلك لاغراض عسكريه
وبحجه اقامه مشاريع البناء التحتيه يوم
الارض ياتي هذا العام في ظل تحديات كبيره
يواجهها الفلسطينيون في اسرائيل وفي
مقدمتها خطط اليمين الاسرائيليه المتطرف
لتعزيز تهويد الجليل والنقب ويضاف الى ذلك
تعزيز الاستيطان والتهويد في المناطق
الساحليه الفلسطينيه التي تسمى المدن
المختلطه كاللد والرمله وعكا وذلك من خلال
تشجيع المستوطنين المتطرفين على السكن في
هذه المدن تحت مشروع البؤر تورتيه
كرست سياسات السلبي ومصادره الاراضي ضائقه
المسكن في صفوف فلسطينيين داخل والذين
تحولت بلداتهم الى تجمعات محاصره
بالمستوطنات اليهوديه التي توسعت على حساب
البلدات العربيه التي تعاني شحا في
الاراضي وتقليص نفوذ ومسطحات وحدود البناء
وفقا لتقارير المركز العربي للتخطيط
البديل
عكست الظروف التي فجرت احداث يوم الارض
سياسات الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه
منذ النكبه وحتى اليوم تجاه الفلسطينيين
في الداخل والبالغ تعددهم الان اكثر من
مليونين وتقلص احتياط الاراضي للعرب
لاغراض السكن بنحو خمسين في المئه علما
انهم يمتلكون فقط نحو ثلاثه في المئه من
الاراضي داخل الخط الاخضر بينما يعود
97% من الاراضي لليهود وتسيطر عليها
الدوله وما يسمى الصندوق القومي اليهودي
ينضم الينا من القدس السيد خليل تفكجي
الخبير في الشؤون الاستيطان سيد خليل يعني
هذا العام كاعوام سابقه يحيي الفلسطينيون
يوم الارض ولكن كيف يختلف الوضع عن ما كان
عليه في السنوات السابقه فيما يتعلق
بالاستيطان وتوسعه
بالعكس تماما ما يحدث الان هو اكثر كارثيه
واكثر نكبه ما كان بالسابق لانه هنالك
يمين اسرائيلي
ذاتيه كامله متكامله ان بين النهر والبحر
دوله واحده وبالتالي يعتبر ان كل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه سواء فلسطين التاريخيه من
الشمال الى الجنوب ومن الشرق الى الغرب هي
وقفيه يهوديه وبالتالي ما يجري الان من
قضيه استيطان وعمليه احلال وعمليه طرد هي
جزء من هذه العقيده والايدولوجيه اليمنيه
المتطرفه نعم كانوا في السابق يسار
اسرائيل
يتكلم شيء وعلى ارض الواقع يفعل شيء اخر
يعني حزبا سبعه وسبعين من سنه 1967 حتى 77
كان هنالك اليسار الاسرائيلي مستلم الحكم
وعندما جاء الحكم 77 حتى جاءت الليكود
طبعا في تلك كانت قضيه يوم الارض عندما
حدثت عمليه تهويد الجليل لانه هذا في
المنطقه كانوا يكتشفون ان هنالك اغلبيه
عربيه في منطقه الجليل وفي منطقه بئر
السبع او منطقه في منطقه بئر السبع باتجاه
الجنوب ان هنالك يوجد عرب ولا يوجد يهود
وبالتالي ممكن ان يكون هذه الاراضي ان
يحدث مع انقسام او حكم ذاتي في هذه
المنطقه وبالتالي بدات عمليه تهويد الجليل
ضمن برنامج واضح هذا البرنامج باغلبيه ان
وضع مستوطنات جديده مصادره اراضي وهو من
سحب ايضا على قضيه 67 طيب اليوم وكما ذكرت
هذه الحكومه توصف بانها الاكثر يمينيه
وتطرفا بالتالي الخلافات التي نشهدها داخل
الساحه الاسرائيليه في الفتره الاخيره كيف
يمكن ان تنعكس على مخططات الاستيطان
هنالك اتفاق بين اليسار واليمين
الاسرائيلي في قريتين معروفه تماما لا
يوجد خلاف في هذا الموضوع القدس كعاصمه
والاستيطان سواء كان في الضفه الغربيه او
في داخل ال 48
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه التي بدات في فتره
حزب العمل واقصد هنا اليسار الاسرائيلي
كانت اكثر وبالعكس تماما ان اليسار
الاسرائيلي فعل في الضفه الغربيه وفي داخل
مدينه القدس وفي 48 اكثر من مفعله اليمين
الاسرائيلي
لكن اليمين الاسرائيلي اليوم اللي هو
المتطرف بدا يظهر وضوح تماما نحن الان
نتكلم في عام
1979 كان هنالك مليون مستوطن اسرائيلي
كانت هناك برنامج اسرائيلي متت ياهو
دروبلس كانت خطته مليون مستوطن اسرائيلي
اليوم نتكلم عن حوالي 750 الف مستوطن
بالضفه الغربيه ايضا في قضيه بئر السبع ما
يجري الان في عمليه بئر السبع والتطهير
العرقي للفلسطينيين الذين يحملون الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا يعتبروها من الدرجه
العاشره وبالتالي عدم البناء والسيطر على
اراضيهم ايضا في الجليل عمليه هدم منازل
وعمليه مصادره مناطق مغلقه عسكريا اذا
انتقلنا الى منطقه القدس شكرا لك ما يجري
في عمليه كارثيه اذا هي
اعتقادي ان اليوم ان اليسار الاسرائيلي
واليمين لا يوجد فرق بينهم
الخبير في شؤون الاستيطان كنت معنا من
القدس
[موسيقى]
الى افريقيا
ومتاعبها وهمومها انعدام الامن في شرق
جمهوريه الكونغو الديمقراطيه لديه تاثير
مدمر على التعليم كما نرى في هذه الصوره
بحيث توقف نحو 750 الف طفل عن التعلم في
المنطقه التي تشهد نزاعا التحذير جاء من
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله يونيسف التي
تضيف ان الفين مئه مدرسه على الاقل اغلقت
ابوابها في اقليمي الشمال كيفو وايتوري
منذ يناير بسبب النزاع السبب الرئيسي
لاغلاق نحو 1700 من هذه المدارس هو انعدام
الامن المرتبط بالجماعات المسلحه التي
تسيطر على المناطق المحيطه
هي تذكره بالفئات الاكثر ضعفا وعلى راسها
الاطفال بطبيعه الحال التي تدفع دوما ثمن
الصراعات والنزاعات والامل كل الامل يعود
الاطفال الى مدارسهم ويستمتعون بطفولتهم
دمتم بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]